where are you she said up the street you
should see me walking you would have
seen her coming down the street
yeah something's definitely going on
with this chick honestly
if that's not her i'm gonna feel
violated
that is a clip from the new season of
catfish airing tuesdays on mtv
and it is the brainchild of our guest
co-host today
neve shulman is here thank you so much
for coming in so you guys are filming
this new season
it's virtual for the first time ever
right the biggest difference is that
rather than taking people
from whatever town or city they live in
across the country to meet this person
we have to just do it virtually via zoom
but in a weird poetic way
it's kind of perfect because that is the
thing that these people should have been
doing this whole time
that's what blows my mind the most neve
is that these people who are dating
online
don't say to someone pretty early on we
gotta get on a zoom catfish often have a
very
good ability to twist that and say well
why do you need to facetime with me you
don't trust me and all of a sudden you
feel bad for asking and you don't want
to screw up this thing
now you've got a catfish podcast coming
out december 9th
and it's been 10 years since that little
documentary
that changed everything so we talked to
you way back when
i have an interest in pushing myself to
do things
challenge myself because of the exposure
and
hopefully the success of the film wow i
almost don't recognize that guy
isn't that crazy i mean i know who i
know it's me
this is you would you give him any
advice uh maybe to have trimmed my chest
hair
sooner because now that i've done that i
gotta say i do like it i mean of course
i interviewed you all season for dancing
with the stars
you finished as the runner-up where do
you sit with that now
emotionally a few weeks later oh i had
this weird moment where we were
waiting for the results and i sort of
said it in my head to myself you know
what
i don't need to win this because i've
achieved what i came on the show to
achieve
which was sort of just sort of believing
in myself